der buchtitel ist eindeutig nicht
verhandelbar integration nur mit
frauenrechten 2018 veröffentlicht julia
klöckner das buch wichtigster punkt der
erfolg einer integration steht und fällt
auch mit der frauenfrage die cdu
politikerin befürchtet mancher
einwanderer bringen einstellungen mit in
denen mädchen und frauen nicht als
gleichberechtigte menschen gesehen
werden
doch es darf keine
parallelgesellschaften ohne frauenrechte
in deutschland geben
denn frauenrechte so klöckner sind in
deutschland nicht verhandelbar so wer
ist denn jetzt politisch dafür
verantwortlich dass sich an der
schlechten situation der frauen nichts
wirklich ändert das war jetzt sehr
pauschal die schlechte situation der
frau habe ich habe frauen glaube uns
geht es ganz gut
da haben wir auch nicht mit
eingeschlossen okay aber ich wollte halt
nur auf die frage an die augen aber wenn
wir uns mal anschauen wie unsere
gesellschaft eine offene gesellschaft
wie sie sich verändert sie ist ja es ist
ja ein atmender dynamischer prozess wir
sind ja ein land das sehr bunt ist und
sehr vielfältig ist und es braucht
spielregeln es braucht eine hausordnung
als ich eben hier ein gang ins studio
stand ganz klar die hausordnung bitte
maske tragen und insofern finde ich dass
dort wo ich reinkomme dass ein land auch
das recht hat klar zu sagen was sind
unsere errungenschaften allein dass wir
frauen hier sitzen das wäre früher
vielleicht abgetan worden als irgend
einer tupperparty dass hier das
ernsthaft was sie drei hier machen ist
etwas dass frauen einen anspruch haben
und das ist hart erkämpft worden dass
frauen kanzlerin werden können dass
frauen chefarzt in werden können dass
frauen das die ehre einer familie nicht
von der sexualität der tochter abhängt
dass frauen entscheiden aus liebe wen
sie heiraten und nicht was väter sich
ausgedacht haben und wir kommen nicht
aus einer heiligen welt und mal kurz zu
sagen dass in deutschland alles klar war
was das thema frauen recht anbelangt nur
was ich nicht nachvollziehen kann ist
dass wir uns über gender gerechter
sprache ewig auslassen können aber wir
finden es als kulturelle vielfalt
wenn die tochter nicht ohne männer
begleitung aus dem haus gehen darf
obwohl sie nun selbst bestimmtes wesen
das wie sollen frauen die voll
verschleiert sind jemals am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilnehmen
können jemals einen beruf ausüben können
oder ihre eigenen rentenanwartschaften
erlangen können und das ist mir ein
anliegen und deshalb sage ich es gibt
spielregeln und wer die nicht einhalten
will sondern segnung in einer offenen
welt will aber ein patriarchalisches
bild mitbringt dem muss man sagen
funktioniert beides wir haben sogar den
awards gesehen sie haben ein buch
veröffentlicht oder dazu da hast du mit
gemacht sein dass es mit vorgestellt
und du hast gerade gesagt dass wir nicht
betroffen sind
die statistik spricht aber der andere
sprache und ich möchte immer in
deutschland anfangen jede dritte frau in
diesem land nicht im ausland ist
betroffen von sexueller körperlicher
gewalt und nur 20 prozent dieser frauen
zeigen dass an das heißt für ziele die
unterdrückung von frauen richten aus
ganz unterschiedlichen gründen ob das
kultur relativistische ist obmann
stabilisiert obmann weg guckt ist ein
weltweites universelles problem das
haben wir auch hier in deutschland
und hinzu kommt dann natürlich wenn man
aus einem orientalisch patriarchalischen
kulturkreis kommt das vielleicht auch
eine zusatzkomponente dazu kommen kann
zumindest zeigt dass sozusagen auch die
erfahrung im umfeld wenn sich frauen zum
beispiel der menschenrechtsverein melden
dann sind haben die häufig muslimische
oder jesidischen hintergrund dazu sagen
meine persönlichen erfahrungs wird aber
ich würde davor waren auch das zu
pauschalisieren sondern es gibt den
überwiegenden teil der menschen und vor
allem der frauen die sich emanzipiert
haben in dieser hiesigen gesellschaft
deswegen greift es zu kurz wenn wir das
sagen nur reduzieren auf die religion
oder die herkunft aber wir müssen uns
sozusagen klar verhalten bei
frauenrechten dass die nicht
verhandelbar sind egal wo und an wem der
kultur die und logisch gebrochen werden
und da sozusagen müssen wir auf beide
seiten gucken also ich glaube die
frauenrechte werden auch lesen dieser
tage ist von sexismus im bundestag ja
das sind ja keine migranten die dafür
sorgen dass die frauen sexistisch
unterdrückt werden sondern das sind
das sind sozusagen vela die ideologisch
so eingestellt sind dass sie sagen
frauen gehören in die küche und an den
herd und da sage ich eben es geht darum
dass man nicht weg guckt also wenn
probleme da sind auch durchaus auch in
orientalisch patriarchalischen
kulturkreisen
aber die frage ist eben was tun mir
dagegen und vor allem wie schützen wir
die opfer und die schützen wir indem wir
eben auch das problem adressieren und
benennen ja welche rolle ganz konkret
die frage an sie spielt in der islam
dabei wir haben jetzt so ein bisschen
drumherum gespurt werden gesagt
orientalisch patriarchalisch nicht wer
du wirklich interessieren
welche rolle spielt der islam dabei in
ihren augen als es gibt nicht den islam
also der der islamische glaube hat ja
verschiedene facetten ganz unterschiede
unterschiedlich und deshalb kann ich
auch schwer sagen welche rolle der islam
spielt für mich spielt die rolle welche
rolle spielen männer mit einem
patriarchalischen bild und da gibt es
sehr unterstellt wird auch religionen
benutzt um eine herleitung ein standbild
über die jahrzehnte und generationen
hindurch festzuhalten
es gibt auch reaktionäre kreise die
nicht islamischen glaubens sind
natürlich gibt es im christentum auch
die frage ist für mich genau das was
diesen tag als sagte überhaupt nicht wo
jemand herkommt was jemand glaubt
sondern wie sich jemand verhält mir ist
egal wo jemand herkommt sondern wichtig
ist wo jemand steht wenn er in diesem
land ist und in diesem land zählt
schlichtweg dass männer und frauen
gleichberechtigt sind
dass frauen sich nicht bedecken müssen
während männern alle gesinnungen der
freiheit haben und das ist mein punkt
das ist mein maßstab und da ist mir die
religion ähnlicher young spielt doch im
islam eine große rolle darin heute gehts
dann lernst du schon gut aber die
bedeckung geht nicht primär ein herr mit
unterdrückung das kann so sein und ich
sage mal
ich plädiere für die frauenrechte und
für religionsfreiheit und ich kann
trotzdem gegen die burka sei aber das
ist für mich das gegenteil davon
denn in dem moment offen ist wie sie in
einer offenen gesellschaft wo ich den
menschen nicht sehen wird er degradiert
und verhütung opfer ist eine auferlegte
freiwilligkeit und unser
verhandlungspartner muss der mann sein
oder die kultur oder der zustand der
dafür sorgt dass die frau sich verhüllt
das hat nichts mehr mit verschleierung
zu tun man sieht diesen menschen nicht
mehr
ja und das ist für mich sozusagen eine
vorstufe
das geht auch zu manifestierung von
sklaven tun würde sogar so weit gehen
wenn ich zum beispiel an die zustände
denke in den herkunftsregionen
vielleicht waren wir noch mal ein blick
zurück auch in diese herkunftsregion ich
würde die these wagen dass die frauen
dort noch viel mehr für frauenrechte
kämpfen müssen viel stärker sein müssen
und das auch tun wenn wir zum beispiel
an den iran denken wo sozusagen auch die
die freiheit sozusagen die die kopftuch
freiheit verteidigt wird dahingehend
dass frauen dafür sterben müssen ins
gefängnis kommen ja gehängt werden dann
ist das ein problem wenn wir auf der
anderen seite in europa im
vorauseilenden gehorsam sagen
integration bedeutet primär immer dass
man sozusagen sich verhüllen muss oder
eine burka tragen muss usw
trotzdem gibt es abstufungen ich kenne
eine menge frauen eingeschlossen meine
eigene mutter und wir sind keine muslime
die früheren kopftuch getragen hat jetzt
so zu tun als wenn jeder den kopftuch
trägt unterdrückt wird und jetzt
sozusagen unsere argumente haben sich
einmischen der freiheit
aber ich würde sagen es kommt drauf an
ich meine es gibt auch beim im
christentum vor 50 70 jahren gab es
frauen
wenn du sie auch hat diese kopfbedeckung
getragen haben und trotzdem sagen es
gibt einen großen unterschied in dem
moment wo mit diesem stück stoff politik
gemacht wird
daran darf man sich eingestanden darf
alles einmischen wenn daraus einen
dominanzverhalten abgeleitet wird
nämlich dahingehend wie ich bin die
beste beschränkung jetzt des individuums
und genau ist ein individuum und wenn
andere darüber entscheiden und wenn ihre
eigene freiheit eingeschränkt wird und
wenn das sogar so weit geht das kleine
mädchen schon also ihr haar bedecken
sollen weil sie angeblich einen reiz bei
männern auslösen dann ist eine des
mädchens problem sondern der mann ist
dann das problem und wer das nicht
ertragen kann ein anblick einer frau
warum soll sie sich verändern kann er
sich halt die augen verbinden und das
ist mein verständnis von freiheit und
von gleichberechtigung und und zu recht
wird in deutschland die stimme erhoben
dort wo es unterdrückung keine
gleichberechtigung bier in der cdu
diskutieren über frauenquoten über
frauenquoten
das sind doch alles themen jetzt kann
doch nicht sein dass wir auf der einen
seite über über sprache sprechen ob man
sternchen schreibt und und ist ein
shitstorm gibt wenn man es vergessen hat
aber auf der anderen seite diese frauen
nicht sieht klar weil sie unsichtbar
sind also und da finde ich müssen auch
acht geben dass nicht sofort immer eine
keule kommt von rassismus islamismus
oder oder oder sonstigen geschichten
nach der religion das recht haben wir zu
glauben egal welchen glaubens so lange
es die freiheit des anderen hat
einschränkt wie ist es denn wenn jetzt
mit denen ca 1500 menschen die jetzt aus
lesbos zu uns kommen auf was müssen sie
sich gefasst machen gibt es eine art was
sagen sie dazu
wie sollen die hier ankommen was hat
unternehmen alle vogue hat ja aber ich
würde jetzt auch noch mal sagen mit
gefasst machen also leute sowie sascha
und mit in deutschland meinte nein aber
ich sag jetzt mal gefasst machen
die menschen wollen hier her als ja ich
glaub die sind gefasst um in die
freiheit zu kommen weil deutschland auch
ein versprechen ist sonst sollte man
hier nicht herkommen und was heißt
gefasst machen aufrechte wir sind ein
rechtsstaat
und das heißt wenn es jetzt um das thema
frauenrechte geht so wie du sind auch
die frage ist ja was hat es mit dem
thema vielleicht bogen hat zu tun
man muss jeden auch individuell
betrachten aber es gilt die ganz klare
regel mädchen haben die chance hier in
die schule zu gehen unabhängig ihres
bruder ist nicht hinter ihrem bruder zu
stehen und haben das recht sich zu
verleben und dass die eltern diesen weg
vorschreiben wie sollen wir dieses recht
durchsetzen wenn wir müssen kann ja
nicht die augen davor verschließen dass
ist dass viele dieser kinder viele diese
familien in ganz anderen strukturen
aufgewachsen so doch patricia
aufgewachsen sind ja wo es in ordnung
ist eine frau zu schlagen und damit wir
uns nicht pauschal sagen genau was bist
du laboratories bisher seien gedroht
hatte dass wir müssen aber es ist klar
dass dort die rolle der frau oft eine
andere
vielmehr hat das ja gar nicht so
abstrakt besprechen ich bin ja eine frau
die genau aus diesem kulturkreis kommt
und ich weiß nicht ob er den eindruck
hatte den dichter drückt werde ich würde
sagen er im gegenteil ich habe für die
emanzipation gekämpft obwohl ich auch
mit anderen werten groß geworden bin und
das finde ich zu pauschal wenn man das
thema gewalt dann immer sozusagen nur
verbindet mit bestimmten kulturkreisen
natürlich ist die rolle der frau in
gewissen konservativen legalistischen
bereichen sozusagen der demokratie nicht
zuträglich aber da setze ich eher bei
uns als rechtsstaat an warum wir
weggucken warum wir das zulassen warum
wir so tun als wenn multikulti die
lösung wäre und warum wir da nicht
direkt rein gehen es geht darum die
unterdrückten zu schützen
egal wo sie herrin und hat auch was
damit zu tun mit klaren spielregeln klar
sie sagten gerade eben na ja die sind in
anderen kulturkreisen groß geworden ja
aber leute selbst wenn ich einem anderen
kulturkreis groß geworden bin will ich
nach deutschland wohl wissen dass es ein
anderer kulturkreis ist gerade weil es
ein anderer ist zum beispiel auch frauen
die sich auf den weg gemacht haben weil
sie sich freiheit erhoffen also ich sag
mal wenn man eine gewisse attraktion ist
verständlich ich würde mich auch auf den
weg machen unter uns gesagt wenn das
möglich wäre
aber dann muss ich doch wissen genauso
wie wenn ich woanders hingehe
welche regeln dort herrschen und ich
glaube unsere kraft liegt nicht darin
dass wir plötzlich beliebig wären werden
sondern im interesse im übrigen auch
dieser frauen die sich von uns was
versprechen viele sind auch enttäuscht
von der gewissheit die fühlen sich im
stich gelassen weil sie sagen ja da
wollen wir uns nicht einmischen es kommt
irgendein moskau leute über ein wehr zu
setzen sind freute es frauen die sich
auf den weg machen leute
das sind das sind ja vor allem männer
die männer das heißt wie schaffen wir
anreize punkte für frauen dass sie über
legale wege möglichkeiten haben sie sich
und ihre kinder was aufzubauen
hier und in der herkunftsregion
[Musik]